Imagine a small patch of strawberries
producing 10 times more fruit than a big
field. That's the promise of modern
growing methods. The cost to start is
higher, but the potential earnings are
much greater. Today, we're talking about
strawberries, a favorite summer fruit.
How we grow them is changing fast. Some
use innovative indoor methods while
others stick to traditional soil. One
method needs significant investment,
special equipment, buildings, pumps, and
lights. The other is cheaper, good soil,
healthy plants, and sunlight. But which
method yields more fruit? That's the key
question. It's not just about more
berries. It's about smarter farming.
Using space and resources wisely is
crucial. Let's explore these differences
and understand them better. The goal to
help you make informed choices. Whether
you're a grower or just curious, this
matters. The future of strawberry
farming is at a crossroads. Let's dive
in and see what's changing. The right
method could transform your harvest. So,
which path will you choose? Let's find
out. Today, we compare two main ways to
grow strawberries. Hydroponics and soil.
Hydroponics is a modern soilless
technique. Soil is the traditional time-
tested method. Which is more efficient?
Which is more profitable? Farmers need
to use resources like water, land, and
time wisely. We'll look at both methods
strengths and weaknesses. Hydroponics
fans call it the future of farming,
citing high yields and efficiency. Soil
growers value tradition and natural
growth. Both sides have strong opinions.
It's a hot debate in agriculture. We'll
explore the advantages and challenges of
each. Our goal give you a clear balanced
picture so you can understand the real
choices. Whether you're a farmer or a
fan, this matters. Let's break down the
facts. Which method fits your needs?
Let's see.
[Music]
Hydroponic strawberries grow fast, much
faster than in soil. Plants get
nutrients directly from water, so they
focus on producing fruit. This means
earlier harvest and more crops per year.
Space efficiency is a huge benefit.
Vertical farming lets you stack plants
in tight spaces, perfect for cities or
expensive land. You can get impressive
yields from a small area. Hydroponics
also saves water. The system recycles it
using far less than open fields. That's
a big win for the environment,
especially in dry regions. Fewer pests
and diseases thrive in controlled
environments. Consistent fruit quality
is another plus. Berries are uniform in
size and taste. Supermarkets love this
predictability. It helps farmers sell
more fruit. Hydroponics offers control
and efficiency. It's a modern solution
for modern challenges. The system is
designed for high output. Every drop of
water and every inch of space counts.
For commercial growers, this can be a
gamecher. The future of strawberry
farming could be indoors, but is it
right for everyone? Let's look at the
challenges. Next up, the hurdles of
hydroponics. Hydroponic systems are
expensive to set up. Pumps, tanks,
lights, and structures all add up. High
initial costs can be a barrier for many.
These systems rely on constant
electricity. Power outages can quickly
damage crops. Monthly energy bills are
significant. Managing nutrients and
water quality is complex. You need
technical skills to monitor pH and
nutrients. Mistakes can be costly. One
error can ruin a crop. Technology isn't
foolproof. Pumps and sensors can fail.
If something breaks, the whole system is
at risk. Hydroponics demands constant
attention and vigilance. It's not as
simple as traditional gardening. The
learning curve is steep for beginners.
Ongoing maintenance is essential. It's a
highreward, high-risk system. Not
everyone is ready for that commitment.
Is the payoff worth the pressure? Let's
compare with soil grown
strawberries. Growing strawberries in
soil is cheaper to start. All you need
is good land, healthy plants, and basic
tools. It's accessible for new and
small-cale farmers. Soil is the plant's
natural home, rich with life. Many
believe soil grown berries taste better,
more complex, and sweet. The living
ecosystem in soil supports healthy
plants. Beginners find soil farming
easier to learn. You don't need advanced
technical skills. Advice from neighbors
or gardening books goes a long way.
There's a sense of tradition and
connection to the earth. Fewer worries
about technology failing. No pumps or
lights to maintain. Weather can be a
challenge, but the system is robust.
Soil farming feels self-reliant and
grounded. For many, it's the heart of
strawberry
growing. Soil grown strawberries grow
more slowly. Plants invest energy in
roots, delaying fruit. Water use is
higher. Much is lost to evaporation or
runoff. This can be a problem in dry
areas. Pests and weeds are harder to
control outdoors. Farmers may need
chemicals or lots of manual labor.
Yields and quality can vary year to
year. Weather plays a huge role. Frost,
hail, or drought can ruin crops.
Predicting harvests is tough. Some years
are great, others disappointing. Nature
sets the pace and the risks. It's less
predictable than hydroponics, but for
some, that's part of the
appeal. Hydroponics can be highly
profitable for large commercial farms.
They supply supermarkets year round,
even out of season. High yields help
offset the initial investment. Selling
when prices are high boosts profits.
Soil farming suits local markets and
organic sales. Lower startup costs help
small farmers. Local sales let growers
share their story. Customers value this.
Knowing your market is key. Do buyers
want perfect fruit year round or local
seasonal flavor? Your resources, money,
skills, land, water shape your choice.
Not every method fits every grower.
Careful planning is essential. Choose
what works for
you. We've seen the main differences.
Hydroponics offers high yields and
control, but costs more and needs skill.
Soil growing is simpler and cheaper, but
less predictable. Your goals matter. Big
profits or a hobby. local sales or
family use. Consider your resources,
money, skills, space, water. Both
methods can produce delicious
strawberries. There's no
one-sizefits-all answer. The right
choice depends on you. Happy strawberry
growing. Whichever path you choose,
enjoy the fruits of your labor.